they say it is apocalyptic heat in
Southwest France insatiable wildfires
are ravaging the forest
as we head towards the fire zone miles
of blackened trees line the root Ash
where once there was life today is very
critical day the problem is the wind we
don't know at the moment uh
which direction it will take these are
already some of the worst wildfires in
memory and they're not yet under control
how long do you think you could be
fighting it then
I think two weeks
and this is the problem the wall of
flames is deep in the forest but moving
quickly moments after we filmed this
we're told it's too dangerous time to go
the wind has changed Direction the fire
could sweep through at any point even
when the fires look small What's
Happening Here is an extremely dangerous
cocktail it's very very dry and the wind
is whipping around just Fanning those
flames
evacuations have emptied streets and
homes in the fire's path but not
everyone is heeding the warning
local officials get a call about a
pensioner refusing to leave her animals
teams are immediately sent to find her
to tell her the fire is coming
but when we arrive she's not budging no
um
she says she's lived here all her life
and isn't going anywhere
the mayor and the police arrive but
there's no changing her mind by staying
here she could die
um no
um I hope not if there is a danger near
her house the people will come here
others have listened in a nearby shelter
we meet some of the thousands of
evacuees who've left their homes they've
no idea how long they'll be here
fire is continuing to rip through
Southwest France this battle is far from
over Siobhan Robbins Sky News gerund
France